had a simple interest work okay I'll
give you the formula and then we'll
unpack it together okay it looks like
this draw it nice and right nice and big
so that we can like point arrows on it
Elaine what's going on okay so this is
about simple interest what are the
pieces here well I I stands for interest
right so this formula once we put all of
them bits and pieces in on the right
hand side it's going to calculate how
much is that one arm what Ali was saying
how much is that excess amount the extra
bit quite apart from how much your
actual theme costs anyone know states
principle that's right not principle as
you like I've got good principles you
know courageous and brain or like I
think you princi-pal just like some
pieces Johnson okay because it also
refers to a sum of money okay see if you
suddenly all right now this our revenue
would be a good word it made sense in
the context but here what it means is
rate okay or interest rate really now
it's quite important that we remember as
well you'll see why later then this is a
decimal we tend to say rates as a
percentage but when we just turned out
five percent twenty percent and so on
okay when you're using the clothes
exodus formula I mean we're going to be
calculating this with calculators right
so we want to input it as a decimal I'll
show you I remind you how to convert
them later either how we were doing that
last week last one
remember I'm trying to work out how much
interest I'm gonna have to pay on
something money I borrowed I need to
know how much I borrow how much they're
gonna charge me as the interest rate
there's one more thing I need to know
hmm remember five dollars right
the longer the longer the bank has it
the more I'm gonna expect them to pay me
right so based on an amount of time
bless you I'm gonna expect more yeah so
that's what this is about it stands for
number of now it does tend to be years
it tends to be used but it's not always
it can be other time periods like weeks
or months those kinds of things so I say
that's lucky right exactly right
the reason why a number of years is the
most common you can even hear it when
people give you interest rates give an
example an interest rate they don't just
say 5% they say 5% and then they put -
that is after what does that stand for P
they fly percent Colorado which means
per year annum as in annual right so it
happens per year so that's why you know
that the most frequent rate is I'm on a
number of years and the questions you'll
get will mostly be like that okay if
it's different the question let you know
okay so let's do an example let's
calculate simple interest I'm just going
to abbreviate because I'm just trying to
write it quickly for you calculate a
simple interest charged
okay how'd it go
now you can see that all the pieces are
here and we want to work out where to
fit them into here so I always start by
writing down well okay I'm just gonna
write down the formula that doesn't get
me any marks or anything like that but
it helps me to know where I'm going to
slaughter the information into okay so
what are the bits that are important P
that's the principle that's how much
you're borrowing okay well how much
you're lending I suppose you give me on
either side that's gonna be this money
this dollar figure here okay
sorry pretty messy okay where's out
raped who is our rate it's 7% now
remember we said it's as a decimal right
so I'm actually gonna write that as see
her [ __ ] her seven good so there's my
right and I'll convert it into a decimal
there okay lastly the number of he's
they even tell you right that's easy to
see because the the time unit is month
days whatever it'll always be there okay
so now let's pop them in interest equals
five thousand times zero point zero
seven like the top e times three years
they go 1000 now just seemed like a lot
of money
let's see you look a lot of money yeah
it's that's right it depends on you know
how long are we willing to hold on to
that money for how long are they willing
to learn up for it's more than it's more
than a fifth of what your actual like
this is the thing that you've bought and
this is the extra that they're gonna
charge you this is the cost of that
money for Holly on two or three years
yes sir okay so the first question was
tackling a simple interest
the second question might be so maybe we
call this Part A Part B might say okay
work out how much has to be repaid in
total
okay
so if I could write something for that
but total that would be the actual
amount that we borrowed which is P plus
the interest we just calculated yeah
that's 5000 plus 1050 we just worked out
okay they go and this is often sort of a
two-step nature of the question read
very carefully whether they want you to
work out the total if you get it in like
an exam paper your underline that word
or do they want you to calculate just
the interest right so that you make sure
you calculate the right number oh one
last thing
remember how we called this PRN
registers on its phone a nedley's number
of years there's an alternative for that
the textbook uses the alternative
sometimes it uses T instead of M what do
you think the T might stand for time
that's right so they just subbing in
it'll be the same number
really but they're just giving you their
different label that's all so don't get
too confused if you see a T instead of
an N there at the end it's the same
formula just wear a slightly different
clothes